that's the difference between a fan
and a viewer that's what goes back to it
goes back to initial point he has
viewers because he's a clown clowns can
have viewers that's fine and you need an
algorithm and you need a platform for
that but if you have genuine fans like i
do they ban me people like to this day
where is tate and they will go anywhere
i am anywhere i am they will come
because they don't believe they can find
my rhetoric or my ideas somewhere else
if you ban logan paul they can find
another [ __ ] to jump around in front of
a camera for you they can promote
someone else inside of their algo and
steal his entire audience inside of a
weak he can disappear and they can
replace him he knows that that's why he
says what he's supposed to say if i stop
being the performing clown the new
performing clown comes the algo favors
him they put him up there and he does a
stupid dance and he gets all my viewers
i'm a completely different kind of fish
different story